me and a couple other guys crawling
around on the floor growling at each
other that was weird I'll never forget
that are you curious about how all the
effects were done in Wednesday well
we've got some secrets to spill about
thing Nevermore Academy and all of the
featured creatures
hello thing number one everyone's
favorite hand is actually attached to a
full-grown man the extremely discreet
and talented Victor dorobantu wears a
full-bodied blue suit to create the
effect of the amputated hand his scenes
involved him twisting and contorting
into hard to reach places often times
crawling on the ground and hiding behind
Jenna Ortega sometimes he would have the
luxury of getting wheeled alongside her
on a camera Dolly check out the way this
underwater scene was filmed fun fact
Victor dorobantu and Christopher Hart
the actor who played thing in the 90s
are both magicians apparently it was
very important for the character of
thing to have dexterity which was one of
the main reasons Victor was cast
surrender
number two remember when she dropped
piranhas in the pool yeah they had to do
a little bit of special effects on the
roof of the school to make it a little
less Normy the school is called
polytechnica University of Bucharest and
it was founded in 1818. the swimming
pool though is filmed at a sports park
in a completely different location in
Bucharest
I'm not sure whose Twisted idea it was
to put hundreds of adolescents in
underfunded schools number three this
would be the monster that Wednesday is
desperate to find the identity of the
Hide was crafted completely with CGI to
achieve that bulging-eyed razor-sharped
tooth and massive Hawking monster
antagonist created by Tim Burton he was
based on a drawing that Tim Burton
designed before shooting even started he
brought a few drawings to the writer's
room and the writers all
enthusiastically agreed on the Hyde
drawing what really went on behind the
scenes while shooting was a lot
different than what we saw on screen the
hide consisted of a man in a full-bodied
black suit with tracking marks all over
it propped up on stilts with crutches
attached to his arms to portray the
massive size of the monster in real time
seeing the much less frightening costume
that Jenna Ortega really had to react to
we're even more impressed by her
performance number four obviously Oliver
Watson isn't a real merman but he's an
excellent swimmer what really went down
in this scene was half practical and
half special effects Oliver Watson
really did swim underwater but instead
of a full-length mermaid tail he just
had on a regular flipper to assist him
in the water as you can see from that
behind the scenes clip he's extremely
comfortable in the water and was
definitely the right choice to
accomplish Bianca in her PO cup scheme
you can even see his mermaid contact as
he does a short video with the cast
thanks
number five also known as kanta kazino
Castle this stunning Romanian Castle got
a spooky makeover to play the role of
Nevermore Academy the castle is actually
pretty inviting when looking at the
exteriors and the bright red roof but
the creators of the show thought the
roof didn't quite match that kooky Adams
Family Vibe so they built on top of it
with special effects you will love
Nevermore
number six remember that time Wednesday
was almost ended like 10 minutes after
she stepped on campus though the scene
was definitely a lot safer behind the
scenes it really wasn't all that safe
Jenna Ortega's stunt double Jenny Ayumi
was really under the gargoyle and it
really did crash down but with little
intermission in between the gargoyle
drops down attached to a wire the stunt
takes place when she is shoved out of
the way
number seven Rowan was definitely
binging stranger things before this in
the scene where he slams Wednesday up
against a tree he gets help from a few
wires behind the scenes and luckily
Jenna Ortega gets a nice mat to soften
the impact they practiced this stunt
with her stunt double beforehand to make
sure it was safe enough for her to
perform I give stunt coordinators such
immense anxiety Jenna was extremely
adamant about doing as many stunts as
she could I will throw myself on the
floor off a wall number eight though
you'd think after two hits were take
taken on Wednesday's life she'd want an
hour or two of therapy but clearly she
has better things to do Jenny Ayumi
fearlessly hops down from the rooftop
and makes sliding down the side of a
building on a wire look easier than it
possibly ever should number nine no
wires just Talent the intense fencing
battle between Wednesday and Bianca was
a stellar introduction to their complex
friendship you must be the
self-appointed queen bee interesting
thing about bees pull out their stingers
and they drop dead okay the word
friendship might be an overstatement but
regardless we get an incredible stunt
sequence out of this classmate conflict
your face finally got that splash of
color it's so desperately needed number
10 some of it was out of Lake and some
of it wasn't the PO cup was filmed
across two lakes in Romania but there
was also a set built at Buffet Studios
there were even some pretty hilarious
mishaps that happened while shooting
causing the entire cast to need a major
wardrobe change this is what could have
happened if thing hadn't saved the day
by decking Kent in the face
number 11. we're talking about
werewolves of course when Enid gets a
visit from her parents she stares in
Envy at the pack she so desperately
wants to be part of we can't really
blame her though these guys can actually
catch frisbees in their mouths that's
pretty impressive the only thing they
really needed assistance with was
getting high enough in the air nothing a
simple trampoline can't fix otherwise a
completely practical stunt number 12.
the quad Goes Up in Flames in the finale
crackstone wasted no time after being
resurrected from the grave
in the show the fire starts off from
this massive explosion courtesy of crack
Stone's magic but behind the scenes it's
much calmer it's clear that the
production crew wanted a safe
explosionless set so CGI definitely came
in handy for that we also get to see
Bianca's incredible wire stunt where she
stands up to crack Stone talk about a
character Arc number 13 poor mayor Noble
Walker the mayor ends up getting hit by
a car sending Wednesday's investigation
in a whole new Direction in the show you
can't even tell that this was a
professionally performed stunt it looks
like he actually gets hit but if you
watch the behind the scenes footage
close enough you can fully see the
little jump onto the hood of the car
causing for a safe performance who did
you think it was behind the wheel when
you saw the first episode blue Cadillac
with no license plates yeah I know
number 14 you'd be surprised how minimal
the CGI was to build the town of Jericho
just little enhancements here and there
to breathe more life into the town it
was impressively built from scratch at
the famous Buffet Studios Eastern
Europe's largest Film Studio it was
supposed to look like a typical New
England town you can see they didn't
spare any details really honing on the
church steeple as it plays a huge role
in the big explosion scene all of the
other stores and shops the florist shop
cobbler shop and thrift store were
actually facades based on Charles Adams
original illustrations number 15 don't
worry we're pretty sure they had faces
behind the scenes these faceless
characters definitely add a touch of
Nevermore spookiness that's so subtle
they're almost easy to miss the way they
achieved this faceless look was by using
a planner tracker to track the actors
faces and facial movements they then
used editing software to remove their
eyes and mouths isolating those images
and placing them onto the facial data
saved for the planner tracker and what
did you think about Wednesday CGI and
special effects it's pretty incredible
how many things were completely
practical from The Sword fights the
major stunts the PO cup and of course
thing what part of the movie Magic was
your favorite
foreign